let's think about what 3
divided by
1 4 is equal to pause this video and see
if you can figure it out on your own and
i'll give you a hint take three holes
and divide it into pieces or sections
that are each one-fourth of a hole and
then think about how many sections you
have
all right now let's work through this
together now let me draw three holes and
so
let's say this is i'm going to hand draw
it so it's not going to be perfect but
let's say that is one hole right over
there
this is two holes
right over there
and then i have my third hole
just like that and now i'm going to
divide it into pieces that are or
sections that are each one-fourth of a
hole
so this first hole is
four
pieces that are each one-fourth each or
four-fourths
and then i have another four-fourths
right over here
and then i have another
four-fourths right over here another way
to think about it i took the three
wholes and i divided it into fourths so
if you divide it into fourths how many
pieces am i going to have
well this is pretty straightforward you
have 1 2 3 4
5 6
7 8
9 10
11 12 pieces and i didn't even have to
count that
each hole is going to be four fourths so
three holes is going to be three times
four fourths or 12
pieces or 12 sections so that is going
to be equal to 12. another way to think
about it is if you take three and you
divide it into equal sections that are
each a fourth you're going to have 12
equal sections